>> Reporter: PRICES ACROSS THE
BOARD WERE SOARING OUT OF
CONTROL.
THE FED NEEDED TO DO SOMETHING.
NOW IT'S A MATTER HOW THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN CAN ABSORB
THIS.
WITH PRICES SURGING AND
AMERICANS STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP,
THE FEDERAL RESERVE TAKES A BOLD
TEP STOOTAME WHAT SEEMS LIKE
RELENTLESS INFLATION AND RACES
INTEREST RATES BY 0.75%, ITS
BIGGEST HIKE IN NEARLY THREE
DECADES.
>> WE AT THE FED UNDERSTAND THE
HARDSHIP INFLATION IS CAUSING.
WE'RE STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
BRINGING INFLATION BACK DOWN,
AND WE'RE MOVING EXPEDITIOUSLY
TO DO SO.
>> Reporter: IS THIS TOO MUCH OF
A HAMMER FROM THE FEDS?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK IT'S A STRONG MOVE BY
THE FEDERAL RESERVE TO ATTEMPT
TO REGAIN CONTROL OF THE
NARRATIVE.
WHAT IT COULD TURN OUT TO BE IS
THAT A LITTLE MORE ACTION TODAY
PORTENDS A LITTLE LESS IN THE
FUTURE.
>> Reporter: A LITTLE LESS WHAT?
PAIN?
>> A LITTLE LESS PAIN, A LITTLE
LESS INCREASE IN INTEREST RATES
IN ORDER TO GET THE INFLATION
JOB DONE.
>> Reporter: IN FACT FEDERAL
RESERVE CHAIRMAN JEROME POWELL
SUGGESTED THE GOVERNMENT LIKELY
WON'T MAKE A HABIT OF BEING THIS
AGGRESSIVE WITH INTEREST RATE
HIKES IN THE FUTURE BUT HE
DIDN'T RULE OUT ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
COMING MONTHS.
WHEN IT RAISED INTEREST RATES A
HALF A POINT LAST MONTH THE FED
EXPECTED THAT WOULD BRING
INFLATION DOWN, BUT IT KEPT
CLIMBING TO A 40-YEAR HIGH.
>> IT WAS QUITE EYE-CATCHING AND
WE NOTICED THAT.
>> Reporter: THIS RATE HIKE WILL
AFFECT MILLIONS OF AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLDS AND BUSINESSES,
PUSHING UP THE COST FOR
PURCHASES.
>> FOR PEOPLE FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS LOOKING TO GET THAT
MORTGAGE RIGHT NOW, THAT'S GOING
TO BECOME MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
THAN IT WOULD HAVE A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE MARKET TO
PURCHASE A CAR ARE GOING TO HAVE
HIGHER BORROWING RATES TODAY
THAN THEY DID THREE MONTHS AGO.
>> Reporter: ALSO FEELING THE
PINCH, PEOPLE LOOKING TO TAP
INTO THEIR RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS
SOON.
>> THEIR 401K BALANCE IS DOWN BY
A LOT, SO THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO MAYBE RECALIBRATE WHEN THEY
CAN RETIRE.
>> Reporter: THE RATE HIKES
COMES ON TOP OF CRUSHING FOOD
AND GAS PRICES, EVEN FORCING
SOME TO CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR.
>> WE'RE CONFINED.
WE'RE KIND OF BEING KEPT
PRISONERS IN OUR OWN SPACES
BECAUSE WE CAN'T AFFORD TO DO
ANYTHING.
>> I AM SO NOT USED TO THIS.
8 GALLONS FOR $40.
THAT'S KIND OF CRAZY.
>> Reporter: EVEN WITH THIS
HARDSHIP THE FED CHAIRMAN SAYS
HE HOPES THE GOVERNMENT CAN
RAISE INTEREST RATES WITHOUT
PLUNGING THE U.S. ECONOMY INTO
RECESSION.
>> WE DON'T SEEK TO PUT PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK.
WE ALSO THINK THAT YOU REALLY
CANNOT HAVE THE KIND OF LABOR
MARKET WE WANT WITHOUT PRICE
STABILITY.
>> Reporter: SO WHAT CAN THE
AVERAGE CONSUMER DO TO DEAL WITH
THIS RATE HIKE?
ANALYST DAVID WILLCOX SAYS RIGHT
NOW IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT NOT TO
OVEREXTEND YOURSELF CREDIT WISE,
TRY TO PAY OFF YOUR CREDIT CARDS
IF YOU CAN, AND DON'T BORROW
MONEY FOR ONE TIME BIG SPLURGES
LIKE VACATIONS OR FURNITURE
PURCHASES.
>> LET'S BREAK THIS ALL DOWN.
MATT, WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US,
FIRST OF ALL, ABOUT HOW THIS
RATE HIKE WILL IMPACT AMERICAN
CONSUMERS?
>> WELL, WOLF, THIS WAS A BREAK
THE GLASS EMERGENCY MOVE BY THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
INFLATION IS ON FIRE AND IT'S
SPREADING.
AND THE FIREFIGHTERS, THE
FEDERAL RESERVE, THEY GOT TO THE
SCENE PRETTY LATE HERE.
NOW THE FED IS MOVING
AGGRESSIVELY.
THE BIGGEST INTEREST RATE HIKES
SINCE 1994 ALL IN AN EFFORT TO
GET INFLATION UNDER CONTROL.
NOW, FOR FAMILIES THIS MEANS
HIGHER BORROWING COSTS, CREDIT
CARDS, MORTGAGES, CAR LOANS,
STUDENT DEBT, APPLIANCES.
THE COVID ERA OF FREE MONEY IS
OVER, BIG TIME.
NOW HOPEFULLY THIS MEANS THAT
PRICES WILL COME BACK UNDER
CONTROL.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT NEWS FOR
FAMILIES WHO ARE DEALING WITH
SURGING COSTS OF EVERYTHING FROM
CARS AND CLOTHES TO FOOD AND OF
COURSE GASOLINE.
BUT THIS WON'T BE EASY.
THE FED HAS TO GET THIS JUST
RIGHT BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T ACT
AGGRESSIVELY ENOUGH ININATION
COULD STAY HOT OR EVEN GET
HOTTER.
BUT IF THEY DO TOO MUCH THEY
COULD ACCIDENTLY CAUSE A
RECESSION THAT COSTS MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS THEIR JOB.
WOLF, THE STAKES HERE COULDN'T
BE MUCH HIGHER.
>> I KNOW.
IT'S SUCH A DELICATE MOMENT
INDEED.
RAHEL, I WANT TO DIG DEEPER WITH
YOU.
IF YOU'RE WALKING LET'S SAY INTO
A CAR DEALERSHIP OR APPLYING FOR
A MORTGAGE WHAT CAN YOU EXPECT?
>> WHEN THE FED RAISES RATES IT
IMPACTS THE COST OF BORROWING
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY.
THE RATES ARE GOING UP SO YOUR
COST OF BORROWING IS GOING UP.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MORTGAGES, FOR
EXAMPLE.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN A PRETTY
DRAMATIC SPIKE IN MORTGAGE RATES
THIS YEAR ALONE.
ONE ECONOMISTS PUTTING IT TO ME
THIS WAY.
YOU PUT 5% DOWN WITH A 3% RATE,
YOUR MORTGAGE WAS ABOUT $1,600.
RIGHT NOW A TYPICAL HOME GOES
FOR ABOUT 350,000, PUT 5% DOWN
BUT YOUR RATE IS 6.1% AND NOW
YOUR MORTGAGE IS ABOUT $2,650.
A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN MORTGAGE
RATES AND COSTS.
THE IDEA BEING IF YOU'RE IN THE
MARKET FOR A HOME YOU MAY
RETHINK BUYING A HOME.
YOU MAY THINK YOU WANT TO WAIT
IT OUT FOR A FEW YEARS, WHICH IS
EXACTLY THE POINT.
THE FED IS TRYING TO PULL DEMAND
AND SPEND LESS ON THESE
PURCHASES TO HOPEFULLY REDUCE
INFLATION IN THE LONGER TERM.
BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE YOU FEEL IF
YOU'RE A CONSUMER YOU WANT TO
BUY OR YOU'D LIKE TO BUY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE AN
APPEAL TODAY TO THESE BIG OIL
COMPANIES OVER THE SKY HIGH GAS
PRICES.
WHAT IS HE ASKING FOR, AND IS IT
LIKELY TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE?
>> THIS IS JUST ONE MORE SIGN
THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO PULL
OUT ALL THE STOPS TO TRY TO
LOWER GAS PRICES FOR AMERICAN
CONSUMERS.
HE WROTE THIS LETTER TO MAJOR
OIL REFINERIES, AND BASICALLY
RAISED TWO POINTS.
HE SAID, ONE, HE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THESE COMPANIES REALLY RAMP
UP PRODUCTION.
AND TWO, HE SAID HE WANTS TO
SEND THE MESSAGE THAT THE FACT
THEY ARE REALLY PROFITING SO
MUCH FROM THIS MOMENT IS REALLY
NOT ACCEPTABLE.
ON THE RAMPING UP FRONT HE SAYS,
LOOK, HE KNOWS THAT PARTICULARLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC A LOT OF
THESE COMPANIES HAVE TO SHUTDOWN
THEIR REFINERIES AND REALLY
REDUCE THEIR CAPACITY, SO HE
WOULD LIKE THESE COMPANIES TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CAN TO
BRING SOME OF THESE REFINERIES
BACK ONLINE.
AND THEN ON THE SECOND POINT ON
THESE COMPANIES HIGH PROFITS HE
SAID, LOOK, AT A MOMENT WHEN THE
AMERICAN CONSUMER IS PAYING SO
MUCH AND GOING THROUGH SO MUCH
TO EVEN FILL UP THEIR GAS TANK,
THAT IT'S REALLY NOT ACCEPTABLE
FOR THESE COMPANIES TO ENJOY
THESE PROFITS.
NOW, WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID IN
HIS LETTER HE IS GOING TO CALL
ON HIS ENERGY SECRETARY TO
CONVENE AN EMERGENCY MEETING AND
HE MIGHT USE SOME OTHER
EMERGENCY ACTIONS TO TRY TO GET
PRICES DOWN.
MAYBE THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT, BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
DETAILS.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
INTERESTINGLY SAID THAT IT IS A
PATRIOTIC DUTY FOR THESE OIL
COMPANIES TO TRY TO TAKE THESE
ACTION